[Musica]
[Applauso]
Buonasera suona la
sveglia riunioni a tutte le ore figli
che dobbiamo accompagnare un po' di
jogging un po' di
yoga che non abbiamo il tempo di vedere
arriviamo alla sera e diciamo Voglio una
vita più
tranquilla questa sembra una scena di un
film di Woody Allen in realtà è una
scena che ha molto a che fare con una
pagina di un filosofo antico che è
Seneca che scrive nel primo secolo dopo
Cristo un trattato che si intitola de
brevitate vite e cioè la brevità della
vita e in pagina e racconta la vita dei
contemporanei romani che sembra la
nostra tutti tesi alla velocità a quanti
più impegni riescano a infilare in una
giornata e per noi anche è così e noi
abbiamo viviamo di quest'idea che
multitasking è bello multitasking è un
valore siamo davvero sicuri che sia così
io penso così con l'idea che mi sono
fatta anche grazie a Seneca ma anche
agli altri studi un po' classici che ho
fatto che in realtà la ricerca
spasmodica della velocità rapina il
nostro spazio e il nostro tempo e io
volevo proprio cominciare da questa
parola spazio che è un po' uno dei due
temi della serata che è una parola
bellissima ve ne individuerà alcune di
parole questa sera spazio è una parola
Secondo me bellissima perché ha dentro
le radici di di un verbo latino che si è
pateo che vuol dire essere aperto chiaro
infinito la parola spazio ha un'idea di
apertura immensità e libertà Ma come
ogni forma di libertà per poter essere
vissuta deve avere un perimetro dentro
il quale vivere e il nostro di perimetro
è dato da due confini se ci pensiamo uno
tangibile del nostro corpo l'altro meno
tangibile è la nostra interiorità intus
Che vuol dire dentro ed exterior che è
la parte che noi mostriamo che sono i
due poli se ci pensiamo che danno l'idea
della nostra unicità Ognuno di noi ha
un'unicità da difendere e siccome a me
piacciono le parole un motivo per cui mi
piace molto Seneca è perché ci sapeva
fare molto con le parole
quando descrive la fame degli uomini
Romani ma non solo di cercare di fare di
fare di riempirsi di velocità sapete
come li definisce occupati che è una
parola che usiamo anche noi non posso
sono occupato Ma Seneca che usava bene
le parole sapeva bene che occupato è un
vocabolo militare a Roma sono i nemici
che entrano con le armi in un territorio
e lo occupano esattamente come un
eccesso di impegni occupa i nostri spazi
e i nostri tempi e allora so Seneca
Scusatemi che oltre a essere un uomo che
ci sapeva fare con le parole ci sapeva
fare anche molto col pensiero aveva
ragionato e costruito un sistema
filosofico che era molto concreto E
aveva molto a che fare con la vita degli
uomini perché questo ha di bello secondo
me il pensiero di Seneca che non ci dà
pensieri astratti ma pensieri che io
spero che ognuno di noi andando a casa
in qualche misura possa mettere in
pratica la sua filosofia Sostanzialmente
è una filosofia Stoica ma qualcosa di
più perché lui prende il meglio dei
pensieri che lo hanno dei filosofi che
lo hanno preceduto fa un po' come le api
che prendono è lui stesso a dirlo no che
prendono di fiore in fiore per costruire
un unico miele e fa un'operazione
culturalmente meravigliosa e cioè sposta
l'attenzione della filosofia dalla vita
politica perché non era stato il primo
filosofo a Roma anche Cicerone si era
occupato di filosofia anche in Grecia
Platone e Aristotele si erano occupati
di filosofia ma lui fa un passo oltre
cioè sposta l'attenzione dalla politica
a quello che noi abbiamo dentro alla
nostra interiorità e fa dell interiorità
e anche dell'intimità che sono Secondo
me due parole molto belle perché
interiorità Chiaramente ha a che fare
con la nostra parte interiore ma
l'intimità è di più intimità
grammaticalmente non vorrei fare la prof
ma qua ci vuole è il superlativo di
intus quindi è la parte come posso dire
quello che noi abbiamo più più dentro
quello che è più profondo e quindi è più
da difendere dagli attacchi ricordate
per non essere occupati e lui crea
questo sistema questo pensiero
filosofico che ci viene incontro e lui
dice signori noi ci lamentiamo Perché
diciamo che la vita è breve la vita non
è breve in sé in qualche caso Purtroppo
sì ma mediamente non è breve Siamo noi
che la rendiamo breve perché la
sprechiamo ce la facciamo rubare e come
si diceva prima ci facciamo rubare il
tempo dice Seneca che è l'unica cosa che
è veramente nostra attenzione con
un'accezione che non è egoistica Eh
perché il tempo per noi noi lo usiamo
Sicuramente per noi ma per tutto il
mondo che abbiamo intorno per le persone
che amiamo e allora vorrei fare un passo
in più Cioè da dove cominciamo uno dice
oggi esco Vorrei sapere come cominciare
Allora secondo me e secondo Seneca dal a
farci le domande giuste Noi siamo
abituati da quando siamo alti così a
pensare a cosa faremo da
grandi non come saremo e secondo me
questo qui siamo molti molti giovani ma
vedo quasi tutti adulti È una domanda
che sarebbe bello anche far nascere sui
nostri giovani cioè chiedere loro non se
vuoi fare l'avvocato la dottoressa la
mamma o il papà Ma quale avvocato
dottoressa mamma o papà vuoi essere
spostare la domanda sulla persona che
vorrai essere facendo l'avvocato il
medico la mamma o il papà e su
tutte avere il coraggio di dire a un
giovane Ma signori anche a noi stessi
che noi vogliamo essere felici e la
felicità La si
costruisce pezzettino per pezzettino la
si ritaglia se impression che aveva
dedicato un epistolario Secondo me
magnifico a Lucilio che comincia così
con tre parole Guardate che sono da
tatuaggio o magari in modo meno eversivo
da così da scrivere su un muro queste
tre parole sono vindica te Tibi punto
che vuol dire rivendicati a te stesso e
siccome lui ci sa fare con le parole Vi
indica gli avvocati a Roma usavano per
indicare la rivendicazione o di un bene
materiale cioè una non so un'eredità che
qualcuno aveva portato via O meglio
ancora per liberare qualcuno dalla
schiavitù Quindi lui dice signori la
prima cosa è un imperativo non è un
consiglio liberati dalle catene che tu
stesso ti sei creato perché spesso credo
che questo lo possiamo dire In molti i
peggiori nemici di noi stessi siamo all
fine noi e il tema che Seneca ci mette
sul tavolo è esattamente questo che non
basta essere al mondo Bisogna vivere e
crearsi degli strumenti sempre essendo
corretti ma degli strumenti
un'intelligenza emotiva per capire la
felicità quando c'è Non quando non c'è
più quella che ci fa alzare volentieri
il lunedì mattina e qui ci viene
incontro una storia che è la storia di
Tello
Tello l'ateniese è una storia raccontata
da Erodoto per chi fosse curioso di
sapere dov'è che è il padre della storia
un autore del V secolo avanti Cristo e
ci racconta nelle sue storie questo
episodio racconta che un giorno Creso
che è il re della Lidia famoso per le
sue ricchezze stratosferiche
accoglie una delegazione di tutte le
persone più famose più importanti della
Grecia fra cui Solone Solone è il famoso
legislatore saggio per definizione gli
fa vedere tutto quello che può con una
certa arroganza tutte le sue ricchezze
allaa fine di questo tour del suo
palazzo Creso chiede a Solone Dai dimmi
tu hai mai visto qualcuno più felice di
me e Solone che non lo vediamo ma ce lo
immaginiamo con un'aria un po' sfidante
gli dice
sì Creso impallidisce e Solone continua
e dice si chiama Tello l'ateniese lui
dice è un uomo semplice che ha avuto due
figli ha visto l'arco delle sue
generazioni crescere e invecchiare è
morto combattendo per la sua patria
prima dei suoi figli e sapendo godere di
tutto quello che la vita gli aveva dato
e aggiunge Io di te non so ancora dire
se sei felice perché questo bilancio lo
si può fare
alla fine Creso poi si ricorderà di
queste parole perché farà una fine
rischierà di fare veramente una fine
molto brutta ma qual è la cosa bella
secondo me che in questa storia c'è la
declinazione delle parole greche e
quindi del concetto di felicità erano
diverse le parole che i greci usavano
per
indicare la
felicità fra tutte Vorrei raccontarvele
tre la e
la
eudaimonia e poi una terza che vi svelo
dopo allora in greco Lo saprete
sicuramente perché c'è anche in italiano
tutte le parole che cominciano per Eu
indicano qualcosa di buono quindi sono
parole positive per cui se la tuche è la
sorte e tuchia vuol dire avere la sorte
dalla propria parte cioè essere
fortunati mentre
eudaimonia vuol dire avere il
diamon dalla nostra parte sgombriamo il
campo casomai ce ne fosse il bisogno
dall'idea che abbiamo un po' così magari
in maniera corrente sul fatto che il
Diamond possa essere un demone per i
greci il Diamond era una sorta di nume
tutelare e Platone ci racconta che
ognuno di noi ne ha uno alla nascita Ma
quando nasce poi se lo dimentica compito
Se volete della la nostra vita
l'obiettivo lo scopo la bellezza della
nostra vita è tirare fuori ricordare
qual è questo Diamond qual è questa
vocazione quello dicevamo prima che ci
fa alare volentieri per fare la madre il
padre la dottoressa o l'avvocato e l'uda
imonia vuol dire avercelo dalla propria
parte questo è il vero secondo me
benessere cioè stare bene nel proprio
posto perché perché abbiamo capito che
stiamo usando lo spazio del nostro tempo
per fare quello che mediamente abbiamo e
amiamo e la passione ci fa ci fa proprio
gustare la terza forma di felicità
invece è quella di Tello ha un nome un
po' particolare si chiama
olbios in greco Bios come biologia è la
vita ol vuol dire tutto insieme no
Quindi olistico viene da questo e cioè è
quella forma di felicità che a me viene
da dire rotonda se posso esprimermi in
questo modo per
cui Tello rappresenta l'uomo che ha
saputo essere pieno di quello che la
vita gli ha dato è pieno Guardate che
nella parola felice c'è Felice ha dentro
la radice Fe Che vuol dire fecondo
Virgilio diceva definiva gli alberi
Felix diceva degli alberi felices cioè
un albero era felice quando dava frutti
noi siamo felici quando diamo frutti e
quti frutti possono essere i figli ma
può essere il lavoro l'amicizia la vita
le relazioni il piacere di fare questo è
un po' a me piace dire anche la
Serendipity dei classici no che uno
legge una cosa pensando di trovarsi
davanti una cosa noiosa greca e scopre
che ha davanti una realtà del tutto
differente non vorrei sottovalutare Ma
ve lo dico solo brevemente che nel
nostro rapporto con lo spazio e il tempo
ha un ruolo fondamentale il corpo
siccome Ormai l'abbiamo capito i greci e
i romani avevano un nome per tutto i
greci ce avevano un grandissimo culto
per una corrispondenza fra la bellezza
esteriore e la bellezza interiore La
chiamavano sembra una parolaccia ma non
lo è calo C agazia Cioè calos vuol dire
bello agazz vuol dire buono la
traduzione un po' pallida bello e buono
ma vuol dire avere una cura e un
rispetto per le dimensioni vi ricordate
che dicevamo l'interiorità e
l'esteriorità che ci compongono così
come i romani usavano l'espressione mens
sana in corpore sano e se ci pensate è
quella a cui ancora noi oggi ricorriamo
se vogliamo pensare a un ozium Cioè a un
riposo a un momento creativo a qualcosa
che ci serve anche per capire come
vivremmo Quegli ultimi 5 minuti della
nostra vita che cos'è che ci accende ora
mi piace lasciarvi con queste due
suggestioni La prima è una terapia
d'urto mi piace chiamarla così e cioè
nelle
scuole filosofiche antiche per ricercare
l'equilibrio e la felicità veniva
insegnata la
meditatio cioè la meditazione
e la meditazione vuol dire quello che
sembra cioè un'azione dell'intelligenza
sapersi
concentrare e riflettere qualche minuto
della propria giornata su una sorta di
riepilogo di quello che abbiamo vissuto
Ma la cosa bella secondo me che a me ha
colpito dal momento in cui l'ho scoperto
è che meditazione haa stessa radice in
italiano e in latino della parola
che si dice medicare e Medicar in latino
medicina e le parole non mentono Cioè è
come dire che meditare è un'azione
curativa nei nostri confronti a me viene
da dire è un gesto di felicità per cui
io vi lascio un po' con
questo augurio e cioè di riuscire in
qualche modo a inserire nelle vostre
nelle nostre giornate un po' di
meditazione un po' di
tranquillità accesa però una
tranquillità sempre
accesa dalle passioni come come se
fosser un'abitudine come noi la sera ci
laviamo i denti e le mani perché io
credo che siano gli strumenti migliori
per diventare i migliori amici di noi
stessi
Grazie
n